bitcoin a peer-to-peer electronic cash
system
first described in a 2008 white paper
authored by the mysterious satoshi
nakamoto the modern financial system
relies on our trust of big centralized
banks to hold our fiat currencies
and execute transactions but trust is a
weakness that eventually requires
intervention by lawyers and government
bitcoin allows two parties to make
reliable transactions
based on cryptographic proof eliminating
the need for a trustee middleman
the optimists call it digital gold the
pessimists call it fool's gold
but in reality it's just software and
like all software its purpose is to
arrange ones and zeros in a meaningful
way
the protocol that makes it meaningful is
blockchain which allows two parties to
engage in transactions denominated in
bitcoins
or satoshi's and just like dollars and
cents they have value
because we believe they do from a
financial perspective the blockchain
is like a shared public ledger that
contains all transactions from all
bitcoin users
and is distributed and synchronized
around the world which eliminates the
need for a central authority to maintain
and validate it
from a technical perspective think of
the blockchain as a database
structured as a linked list where each
record or block
represents a group of transactions that
have been permanently committed to the
database
it works kind of like a git repo that
can never be rebased the important thing
is that each new block is
linked to the previous one in the
blockchain and its creation goes through
a very strict set of cryptographic rules
each user or wallet has a unique public
key for receiving money
kind of like a username and a unique
private key for spending money
kind of like a password but before you
can spend money you'll need to prove
that you're the owner of a public key
that money has been sent to in the past
each transaction contains a hash or
encrypted representation
of the previous transaction and the new
owner's public key
the hash is then signed with the
previous owner's private key
this makes it possible to validate the
chain of ownership without the need to
expose
the private key and the signature makes
it virtually impossible to
alter the transaction after it's been
issued but what if somebody tries to pay
two different people with bitcoin at the
exact same time
or double spend their money that's where
mining comes in which is a system that
allows multiple computers around the
world
to agree on the appropriate state of the
entire system or ledger
each new transaction is broadcast to all
nodes in the network
the transactions are packaged into a
block then miners will expend computing
power to validate proof of work
they compute a proof for a random
problem that is very difficult to solve
but very easy to verify
the first miner to solve the proof which
happens via dumb luck
gets a portion of the bitcoin as a
reward the block is then broadcast back
to all
other nodes where it's permanently
confirmed on the blockchain this has
been bitcoin in 100 seconds
if you want to see more short videos
like this make sure to like and
subscribe
and if you really want to learn how
blockchain technology works stay tuned
because today we're going beyond 100
seconds to build a blockchain from
scratch with node.js and typescript and
in the process
you'll learn all kinds of useful
information about cryptography
whether you're into cryptocurrency or
not there's many concepts in
cryptography that you should know about
as a developer
things like encryption and signing
hashing functions and algorithms like
sha
rsa and md5 that make all this stuff
possible
over the next few minutes you'll learn
about these concepts by implementing
your own blockchain from scratch
using nothing but node.js and typescript
our blockchain will contain wallets
where users can send money back and
forth
each transaction is added into a block
then that block is mined with a proof of
work system
at which point it can be added and
confirmed on the blockchain and
throughout this process you'll learn
about
all kinds of important concepts and how
they apply to different areas of
development
to get started you'll need node.js
installed on your system
then we'll open up vs code to an empty
directory run npm init y
to create a new node.js project i'll be
using typescript in this code
because we'll be using object-oriented
programming principles to implement the
blockchain and having types will just
make our code a bit more readable
you can install it with npm then create
a ts config file
and copy and paste the values from the
main source code from there we can go
into our package json
and create a script called dev that runs
the typescript compiler with the watch
flag
to constantly compile our code in the
background to plain javascript from
there you should be able to run
npm run dev from the command line to
keep typescript running in the
background
now we'll write all of our source code
in the index cs file
at the top of that file we will import
the crypto library which is a built-in
in node.js as the name implies it's a
modular node that handles a bunch of
different functionality for cryptography
our simple blockchain implementation
here has four classes
a transaction a block a chain and a
wallet
let's start by implementing the
transaction which is the fundamental
purpose of any cryptocurrency
transfer funds from one user to another
user in a transaction
a transaction object has three
properties the amount of the transaction
denominated in bitcoins or fire coins or
whatever you want to call your coin
along with the person paying the money
and the person receiving the money
eventually we'll set up public keys for
these users which you can think of as a
username that will eventually set as
these values in the transaction
one final thing we'll do here is add a
method to the class to convert the
object to a string
as we go through the tutorial we're
going to serialize everything as
strings just to make the cryptographic
objects easier to work with
and now we're ready to move on to the
block implementation
a block is like a container for multiple
transactions
or in our case just a single transaction
to keep things simple
you can think of a block like an element
in an array or more accurately a linked
list
because each block has a reference or
link to the previous block in the chain
with the previous hash property and that
brings up a good cryptographic question
what is a hash a hashing function allows
you to take a value of an arbitrary size
like say a transaction then map it to a
value
with a fixed length like a hexadecimal
string the value returned from the
hashing function
is often called a hash or a hash digest
when you create a hash it cannot be
reversed to reconstruct the
contents of the original value but what
you can do is validate that two values
are identical
by comparing their hashes and that's
important for a blockchain because it
ensures that two blocks can be linked
together without being manipulated
now to create a hash of a block we're
going to implement a getter
that will first stringify the object
itself then we'll use the create hash
function from node crypto
which specifies a specific hashing
algorithm in this case
sha-256 it stands for secure hash
algorithm
with a length of 256 bits it was
developed by the nsa back in 2001
and it's what's known as a one-way
cryptographic function
which means that it can encrypt data but
it cannot decrypt data back to its
original form
we can use the function to hash the
string version of the block
then return the hash value or digest as
a hexadecimal string
and that's all it takes to build a block
in this case it's a transaction
that has a link to the previous
transaction in the form of a hash
and it also contains a timestamp because
all blocks will be placed in
chronological order
now we can move on to the chain which
again is like a linked list of blocks
there should only be one blockchain so
we'll go ahead and make it a singleton
instance
by setting up a static instance property
that is equal to a new chain
instance that'll just ensure that we
have one chain instance instantiated
before anything else
now we can declare a property for the
chain itself which is just an array of
blocks
in the constructor we'll define the
first block in the chain which is called
the genesis block
the previous hash is null because
there's nothing for it to link to
then it instantiates a new transaction
that transfers a hundred coins to
satoshi
notice how we're creating money out of
thin air here that's no different than
when the central bankers or federal
reserve turn on the money printer
now in the blockchain class we'll often
need to grab the last block in the chain
so we'll go ahead and create a getter to
help us out with that
then we'll define a new method named add
block that takes a transaction
the sender's public key and a signature
that we can verify
before adding a new block to the chain a
naive and simple implementation might
look like this
we instantiate a new block taking the
last block's hash and this new
transaction
then we push that new block onto the
chain but the problem is that there's no
way to know that this is a legitimate
transaction
anybody could send arbitrary transaction
data to transfer
coin to someone else we can allow people
to securely send coin back and forth by
implementing a wallet
which is essentially just a wrapper for
a public key and a private key
the public key is for receiving money
the private key is for spending money
to generate a public and private key
we're going to use a different algorithm
called rsa
which stands for the names of the guys
that created it and unlike
sha this is a full encryption algorithm
that can encrypt data
and then decrypt it if you have the
proper key to do so to encrypt a value
you would use the public key to convert
it to ciphertext which is an unreadable
version of the original value then you
would use the private key to decrypt it
back to its original form
but what we're actually more interested
in is using the key pair to create a
digital signature
with signing we don't need to encrypt
the message but instead create a hash of
it we then sign the hash with our
private key
then the message can be verified later
using the public key if anybody tried to
change the message it would produce a
different hash in which case the
verification would fail
and that's really important for a coin
because if we didn't have a signature
then someone could intercept the
transaction message and change the
amount or change the payee
with no way to detect that anything was
out of the ordinary
now when generating the key pair with
node crypto i'm going to format them as
strings
and to do that i'm going to add some
extra options here for encoding the
important one to know
is the format pem which you would
normally save to a file
on the user's computer system where it
could be reused in the future
now that we have a public key and
private key we can use it to send money
to another user
the way we do that is by specifying an
amount and the public key
of the user being paid we can then use
node crypto to create a signature
again an sha 256 format using the
transaction data as the value
we can then create a signature by
signing it with a private key
this is kind of like creating a one-time
password it allows us to verify our
identity with the private key without
actually having to expose the private
key the signature depends on both the
transaction data and the private key
but it can be verified as authentic
using the public key we can now attempt
to add that block to the blockchain by
passing the transaction
the public key and the signature in real
life those values would be transferred
over the internet
then the signature could be verified
let's go ahead and refactor the add
block method
in the chain class it'll use node crypto
to create a signature verification
then pass the same transaction data to
the verifier we can then validate it
by verifying that the transaction data
has not been tampered with
using the sender's public key and the
signature itself
and we're now able to securely verify
that that user is actually trying to
spend that amount of money to the other
user
but there's still one more big issue
with our blockchain and that is the
double spend issue
imagine the spender tried to send money
to two different users at the same time
they could potentially spend more money
than they actually own before their
transaction is confirmed on the
blockchain
the way bitcoin addresses that issue is
with a proof of work system which
requires
each new block to go through a process
called mining where a difficult
computational problem is solved in order
to confirm the block
but it's very easy to verify that work
by multiple other nodes on the system
when mining is distributed around the
world it means you have multiple nodes
competing
to confirm a block on the blockchain and
works like a big lottery the winner of
the lottery earns a portion of the coin
as incentive
which motivates people to invest in the
computing resources to mine a coin
and also to pump the price of the coin
higher and higher because the higher the
price the more money you make
you can think of it like converting
cloud computing resources into money
now to implement a basic proof of work
system we'll go back into our block
class
and add a nonce value which is a
one-time use random number
then in the chain class we'll add a
method called mine that takes that nonce
as an argument
what this method will do is attempt to
find a number that when added to the
nonce
will produce a hash that starts with
four zeros the only real way to figure
out that value is with brute force by
creating a while loop that goes digit by
digit
until we find the requested value to
handle the brute force computation
we'll create a while loop that creates a
hash with the md5 algorithm
it's very similar to sha-256 but is only
128 bits
and is faster to compute we'll continue
to create new hashes
inside the while loop until we find one
that starts with four zeros
when we find it we can return the
solution and then send it off to other
nodes where it can be verified
and the block can finally be confirmed
on the blockchain and that takes care of
our blockchain implementation
if we go down to the example usage here
you can see we instantiate a few wallets
for different users
then allow those users to send money to
each other using their various public
keys
if we go ahead and log out the chain
itself you can see we have a bunch of
blocks or transactions linked to each
other
based on a hash of the previous block
now this blockchain is obviously not
perfect
and something that i just hacked
together to teach you the gist of how a
blockchain works
feel free to grab the full source code
on github if you learned something in
the process
please make sure to like and subscribe
and consider sending me some bitcoin or
sponsoring me on github for just one
dollar a fiat per month
i use all that income to sponsor other
developers myself
thanks for watching and i will see you
in the next one